- What is the cost of downtime?
I would like to start with the reality
we are facing in today's digital world.
What you see on these slides
represents the true
impact of system failure.
According to the information technology
in diligence consulting,
9% of the enterprise
are losing 300,000 plus
per hour of downtime.
Plus 41% of the enterprise,
are losing between one to $5 million
per hour of downtime.
But these are just numbers.
These are missed opportunities,
damage to customer relationship,
loss of productivity,
and also, a hit to the brand's reputation.
But think like that this,
is not just an IT problem,
it's the business survival.
Today we're gonna talk about
building resilience systems,
doing effective observability.
And then at the end,
we'll be gonna show you
two demos using Gen AI.
My name is Matheus Canela.
I'm a Senior Solutions
Architect based in Sydney.
And today with me I have Jay,
who is a Senior Cloud Support engineer,
based in India.
Jay.
- [Jay] Hi everyone.
So what do we have for today's agenda?
First, I'll go through
the Resilience foundations
and best practice.
And Jay will take control and talk about,
how to observe, detect, and investigate.
So think about metrics, logs, and trace.
Also, how to use the alarms and tools,
for you to investigate.
And at the end, I'll show you a demo
on how to do a full troubleshoot,
and then solve a problem
with generative AI tool.
Alright, first is resilience foundations
and best practice.
Before we dive deep
into technical aspects,
I wanna share with you
a personal real story
that demonstrates how resilience
is critical for every
technology implementation.
So stay with me.
One year ago I decided to
fully automate my house.
And then as you can see,
that represents by the house.
And then because my house is not that new,
I had to use, you know, wireless protocol.
I couldn't use cables to connect
to the lights or to the appliances.
And then if you see, I
had a wireless switch,
and this wireless switch
used a dedicated channel
with specific protocols.
I also had wifi lights,
which uses the wifi signal.
So to have an idea,
if you press the wifi switch
that goes to the home controller,
the home controller then decides
where, you know, which lights in the house
we need to turn on.
So, as you can see, it
turns on the lights.
So as we all busy, I had
to do this after hours.
And around 1:00 AM when
I was about to finish,
I just deployed an update,
and then I went straight to bed.
So, during the night the server failed.
And then what happened is, the network
used by the wireless switches also failed.
And you can start guessing
what happened, right.
So the wireless switch became unavailable.
But then, my wife woke
up at 5:00 AM right.
She needs go to work,
and then you know, take a shower,
prepare her breakfast.
And then in Sydney,
there's no sunlight around 5:00 AM,
So, she relies on the lights,
you know, to do her stuff.
But I was sleeping,
and then she had no lights.
And you can start expecting
that she was really, really upset.
And you also maybe thinking,
you know, what happened
to me at that time?
- [Jay] I think you're in trouble Matheus.
- Yeah, I was in a big
trouble at that time.
So, but what I wanna do now,
is just go a little bit
deeper in the conversation
I had with her between, you know,
when she actually
figured out that problem.
So, one to two minutes of that discussion,
and you see how that relates
to your day-to-day business.
So, she first woke me up saying,
you know, Matheus, what
happened to the lights?
I just woke up a little
bit nervous, you know.
5:00 AM don't like
waking up in the morning,
said, I don't know, why?
And then she just said,
they're not working.
Or good, aren't you now, right.
So, it's expected as we discussed.
But, I want you to pay attention
to the next thing that I said to her,
which is basically what customers
are doing nowadays today customers.
I just said, well, the SLA for the lights
is five hours, and then you have to wait.
But, and then you see
the next conversation,
go like, What is that SLA?
Right, so, and that's what happened
to a lot of business nowadays.
When you have, you know,
that type of issue,
they don't know that SLA exists.
She may be expecting
the lights to be 24/7.
Who would expect the lights, you know,
to have a failure or you know,
a server that would impact that to work.
But now let's start
bringing that personal story
into how can we build it on AWS.
So first, if you see,
my home controller was a
single point of failure.
When it crashed, every
light stayed off, right.
So if you think about this,
we have the availability zones impairment.
And then availability zones
are isolated file domains,
with independent power,
cooling and network.
But, availability zones can also fail.
And that's why it's
important, you know, for you
to think about having
a multi AZ discussion.
So resiliency start with redundancy
across multi AZ.
So I wanna talk about two services,
they're not the only one available
for talking about, you
know, multi AZ discussion.
And the first one is
elastic load balancing.
So imagine if one AZ fails
or one node has an issue,
elastic load balancing can shift the load
to the next node, in a different AZ
if that's failing like a help node.
And it also applies to RDS multi AZ.
So imagine if you have an instance
of a database failing one AZ,
it can shift the load to the other AZ.
So the next one is,
I deployed things using click ops,
which makes it harder to roll back.
So that links to
misconfiguration and bugs.
So human error remains
the major source of incidents.
And the best defense is
treating infrastructure
like an application code.
So, no more click ops, right.
In that case we can talk about two things.
The first one is using a report storage
to store your codes.
But we also talk about
cloud development kits,
which is the CDK.
So, if you're writing your infrastructure,
like your database, you know your servers,
your network, all through as a code
in a type script for example.
You can then once you deploy it
becomes a cloud formation,
but can also become a terraform.
And you can even use
cloud formation directly,
if you like.
So the next one is the alarm
could have triggered my home-lab recovery
before my wife discovered
the outage, right.
So...
I'm just clicking the next one.
And that links to excessive loads.
So in that case we can have
for example, out scaling.
If you're having a spike in connections
to your web server, right,
then you can add and remove service
to cap with that load.
And then not everyone is aware of,
but we also have application out scaling.
So you have the out
scaling as I mentioned,
for your EC2's.
But if you have Aurora read replicas
or Lambdas or even DynamoDB,
the application out scaling
can also help you in that.
And talking about Lambdas,
it's important to think
about managed service.
Like lambda, DynamoDB,
or those servers can help
you manage, you know,
the requests without
managing the infrastructure.
And lastly, I never test
my lighting recovery
playbook until 5:00 AM
So game days could have helped the family.
So, think with me, if
you remember the network
for the switches was failing, right
But my wife was not
aware that using an app
could have turned it on the lights.
And that's why game days
is really important,
so you get the whole, you know,
in my case, the family,
but you can have the whole company
getting together to understand.
If there's a bad day, what should I do?
So, in that case I want to talk about
two services, AWS fault injection service,
which allows you to inject fault
in your environment,
in a controlled manner.
So, it can terminate,
since you can you know,
isolate an AZ.
And we also have the security hub.
No, not the security hub.
It's just hiding there.
- [Jay] Resilience hub.
- Yeah, the resilience hub.
So, in that case you can
import an application
and run a report on that.
And you can understand
how your application
will behave in case of a failure.
Alright, so this screenshot here
represents the fault injection service.
If you open that in a console.
And I want to highlight
two of the servers,
not just the two,
but you have many as you
can see that page can,
you know, you have two pages there.
The first one,
is the availability power interruption.
So in that case you can inject
a failure in the AZ,
and see how your application behaves.
And then the second one is the EC2 stress,
that you can do in a CPU.
So you can simulate and
stress in your environment
to see how your application behaves.
And then those thoughts
that you can inject,
help you think about, what happened
if one of one part of
my application fails,
how is that gonna behave?
All right, I want to jump now
in the other service
that we mentioned before,
which is the resilience hub.
Before I show you reports generated
by resilience hub,
I wanna show you the infrastructure
that I ran the reports.
So think about this as a single AZ, right.
And in that single AZ,
I have a single RDS, right.
So, single instance of the database.
I also have elastic load balancer,
out scaling group and SG,
but they're irrelevant
for the reports I'm gonna show you.
So in that case here,
once I import that application
into resilience hub,
I can generate reports
about the infrastructure.
And then I set up the RPO and the RTO,
which is a recovery time objective,
and the recover point objective,
to be only five minutes.
So, if I run the reports,
you see that says it's
unrecoverable, right.
And you may start thinking why?
Why it's unrecoverable?
So if you look down the report,
it's saying the database
cannot recover within that five minutes.
If you remember my infrastructure,
I only had one database in one AZ..
So if that database fails,
you won't be able to recover.
And that's where the resilience hub
is really important to help you
with your secure resilience posture.
Alright, let's change gears a little bit,
'cause I don't wanna forget
to talk about trade offs and risks.
If you remember my use case,
imagine if I want to
have multiple servers.
Multiple wireless network,
just in case you know,
I have an issue with the lights.
Is that a cost effective?
And that's why you need
to think about that
when you talk about resilience.
So, if you have critical applications,
it's really important.
Okay, invest time, engineering time,
and make that resilience.
But, if it's not a critical application,
it's also important to
understand the risks
and take that in consideration.
Right, before handing back to Jay,
I wanna talk about
Reliabilty improvement cycle.
So, first, resilience architecture
from the ground up,
we already discussed that.
And then, next is how to observe.
So think about the
metrics you can collect.
What is the information you can get
out of your platform?
And then how you detect, right.
So if you have that information,
are you getting an alert?
How you know that there's a problem
with your environment?
And then how you investigate?
How you get to the root cause.
And lastly, how you resolve?
How you get this back
to where it's supposed to be.
But, if you link that in a circle,
that's why it's really important
to keep, you know,
get stronger and more reliable.
So now I give back to Jay,
who will continue with the presentation.
- Thanks Matheus.
Alright, so let's talk
about observability.
So, I think it's a little
hard to spell, I think.
But let's try to make it simpler
in the next few slides.
So, how many of you are operating
and managing microservices
or distributed systems?
Can I get a raise of hands?
Like, yeah, quite a few
hands raised, right.
So you know, right that,
managing and operating these systems
is really complex.
There are multiple services
that communicate with each other.
Like you have lots of microservices,
your databases, maybe
your queuing systems,
all you know, distributed and scattered,
as you can see, like these blocks.
And then, they try to communicate
with each other,
and you might even not know
when a new dependency
is even added to that, right.
So when something breaks in that system,
you are just guessing that, okay.
Is it the service that has, you know,
causing the problem?
Or is it the dependency you know,
that is failing?
Or is it the network?
You know, it can be DNS.
Or it's always the DNS, right.
So yeah, so without observability
you are actually flying blind.
So this is where we want to get
with, with proper observability, right.
So, now everything changes.
You now see the exact
shape of your application.
Like, how each and every
service is interacting.
And how each and every dependencies
are interacting, with your services.
And then if something fails,
you are immediately able to understand
where to look and what is breaking, right.
But, to get here, you need to track
or monitor the right signals, right.
So let's look at that.
So to elevate your
application reliability,
you need to measure what
actually matters, right.
So let's talk about
some of the key signals.
So first, you always start
with the business, right?
So metrics, like let's say revenue impact,
the number of transactions
or the number of orders that you process,
can be something that actually shows you
some business outcomes,
or anything that relates to your business.
So for example, let's say
if your checkout service fails,
you know exactly how many
orders you're losing,
with your customer,
and what is the revenue impact, right?
So, this helps you to also drive
your service level agreements
with your customer.
Which is nothing but the promise
that you make to them,
that, hey, my platform or my service
will be up for let's
say, 99.9% of the time.
And if you're not able
to deliver that promise,
you know exactly what
is going to impact you.
The next set of signals,
are user experience.
So, these are very critical
because this helps you to understand
how your customers are experiencing
your application, or
let's say your website.
So, you can monitor the
core web vital metrics
like the Largest Contentful paint,
interaction to the next point
or cumulative layout shift.
So, let's take an example
of how this actually helps.
So let's say if your metric,
let's say Largest Contentful Paint
is actually increasing from let's say,
two seconds to five seconds,
that means that whenever a user
is actually loading your website,
it is taking a longer time
for them to load your
content on the website.
And that means,
that they might abandon the session.
And then they might go somewhere else,
and you know, drop from
the platform, right.
So that's why it is very important,
to measure the customer experience.
Like, how they're
actually using application
using these core web vitals.
And these are standard metrics
that you can always use and monitor.
The next set of services
are your service health metrics.
So these are metrics
such as the number of requests, right.
About how the services
are handling the request,
or how many errors it
is, you know, observing.
Or your latency.
Your P50, P95, or P99 percentiles, right.
So always use percentile,
don't use averages,
because averages can hide your, you know,
bad customer experiences,
you know, so that's why.
So, measuring these will
help you to understand
like how your services are performing.
And it'll tell you exactly
whether a service is
healthy or not, right.
So, once you start tracking
all these signals together,
you can actually understand
and completely you know,
understand how your
reliability is working.
And then finally,
you have your reliability targets.
So, who here measures SLOs?
Can I take a see a raise of hand?
Okay, very few.
But yeah, that's good.
So, I really want to dive deep
into why SLOs are important
for measuring reliability.
So, let's take a look at that.
So, when you're defining your SLOs,
you always start with your end customers.
Like what are they expecting,
or what from your
application or your platform.
So, you start with that,
and then you decide or
give a promise to them.
Like, hey, our platform would be up
for 99.5% of the time.
That's the promise that you're making.
And if you're not able
to meet that promise,
we will give you,
let's say, some kind of credits.
So, in order to then achieve this promise,
that you're making to your customer,
you define your service
sale objectives, right.
So this is an internal
target that you take,
and you work with your engineering team.
So for example, this
would be slightly higher
than the actual SLA.
Let's say 99.9%.
And the difference between
your internal target,
and the actual customer promise,
will give you the error budget.
So this is something
that will help you to, you know,
deploy new features,
new versions of your application,
and still be able to make sure
that the applications are reliable.
But how do you know
that you are meeting these targets, right?
So for that, you start measuring SLIs
or Service Level Indicators.
So these are actual metrics
like latency, error uptime.
So you basically create SLO,
which will track this
service level indicator
over a period of time.
And then that will give
you an understanding,
like whether you're able
to meet the targets or not, right.
So, doing all this will help you
to actually, you know,
make your reliability measurable.
And you can always track and improve it,
as in when you are not able to, you know,
deliver your promises.
So, measuring these metrics,
or deriving these metrics,
can be, you know, challenging.
Because you might have to maybe,
let's say change your application code,
add some libraries to it.
Create some custom, that sort.
That's why we introduced
Amazon CloudWatch Application Signals.
So this is a tool, that
you can now start to use,
to basically monitor
the health and performance of your system.
And it'll allow you to track
your business goals as well,
alongside your system performance.
So let us see what you get out of the box
for application signals.
So the very first thing is,
once you enable application signals,
it uses open telemetry
auto instrumentation method
to derive or extract all
the metrics and traces
from your services, right.
So you don't have to make
any application code changes.
And you can literally get
started within minutes
to get those critical metrics
and traces out of your system.
Second, once you enable it,
it allows you to discover
all your services and dependencies.
And you can visualize them
in a graphical way or a map view.
And then it also gives you
some prebuilt dashboards.
For example, what is the
health of the services?
How are they performing?
How many faultst hey have?
All these things, into this dashboard.
And finally you actually track
what matters, right.
So, it gives you the golden signals
like your latency error faults.
And then you also enable
distribution pacing
to get end to end visibility.
And then finally, it allows you
to natively track and monitor
service cell objectives
within Amazon CloudWatch.
So, let us now see,
actually how application signal works.
So this is one of the screenshots,
that I've taken from
my sample application.
So, you can see here at the bottom
in the highlighted section
that we have five services,
that got automatically discovered
once you enable application signals.
And then in the same dashboard,
you also get this widgets,
that will quickly show you
which services are, you know,
observing some faults.
So, here you can see
that there are a few services.
Like let's say the front
end service is observing
some two and a half percent of faults.
So now, if you want to dive deeper
into what is happening with the services,
you can go and check
this individual service held dashboard,
from application signals.
So here in the center, you see
all the golden signals, which I mentioned.
And then if I just observe here,
I see a request spike,
which the service, you know, handled.
And then at the same time,
I see this spike in the number of faults.
You know, that were
observed on the service.
So that means that
there was some problems,
and the service might be overwhelmed
because of the spike.
So when you click on this
particular data point,
or point in time,
you will automatically be taken
to the correlated traces.
So you can see here in the, you know,
bottom right, you get
the list of trace IDs
or the traces, that are, you know,
correlated to this
particular point in time.
So now, you can use these traces
and you know, you can easily identify
how the request travels
from one service to another.
And then at which point
the fault was introduced, right.
So, without you doing
the correlation manually,
this gets automatically added,
using application signals.
So here is an example
of an application map,
that you get, once you
enable application signal.
So using this, you actually see
how each and every service are connected,
and communicate with each other, right.
So in ,the earlier part
I mentioned that, right.
Like how critical it
is for you to visualize
and understand how each
services are connected.
So every node here,
as highlighted is your service,
that you are running as
part of your application.
And then every line here,
shows the dependencies,
which these services are
interacting with, right.
And then, and again, from here,
you can go from, you know,
this map view, to the
individual service held
dashboard very easily.
And finally, as we were talking about SLO,
so using application signals,
now you have a native way
to define and track and measure SLOs.
So using this, you can easily see
which SLOs are, you know,
you are able to meet the target.
What is your remaining error budgets.
You know, so the SLA team
can keep tracking and
monitoring this dashboard.
And they can work with
the development team,
if you know you are all, you know,
close to exhausting your
error budget, right.
So now, we have got the right signals '
for our systems.
So, let us try to see how
we can use this signals
to quickly detect any failures
so that we can act upon it, right,
if something goes wrong.
So in distributed systems, you know,
failures are inevitable, right.
You never know when a dependency
or service will go down.
But the real question
is, do you know about it,
before your actual customers comes to you
and complain about it, right.
So that's why we need to detect
these failures as fast as we can.
And there are two approaches
I just want to talk about.
So let's start with talking about
lagging indicators, right.
So these indicators are
basically telling you,
that something is already
broken in your system.
And then for example, let's say we saw
a spike, right, in the request.
So when a spike hits, it elevates,
let's say your error rate,
let's say from 0.5% to 20%, right.
So that's a, that's a
huge difference, right,
From 0.5 to 20%, right.
Or let's say your team, you know,
deployed a, a new version of the code,
and that broke a critical service,
and which then cascaded
to further services
which were relying on it, right.
So, once you know this
kind of failures happen,
you are actually firefighting.
And your customers are already impacted
through this indicators, right.
So most of the teams are here, right.
We all start with, you know,
identifying lagging indicators.
But then let's talk
about leading indicators,
and how they can help.
So leading indicators are something
that will tell you that a problem
is going to develop,
and it can be critical
so you can identify it,
before it actually impacts your customers.
So things like, let's say your API latency
is gradually increasing,
let's say from a hundred milliseconds
to 200 to 300 or a week of time
or a day, some time.
Or let's say your disc pace utilization,
very simple metric, right.
But it can also grow up in size,
let's say 5% day by day.
And then gradually it'll hit the limit,
and you know, there will be something
going wrong with the service.
So all these indicators,
if you are able to identify,
will give you enough time
to act upon it, right.
So you can, let's say for example,
you can scale your capacity,
you can tune the performance
and prevent the problem
before it actually hits your customers.
So the key takeaway here, is as a team
or as an SRE engineer for example,
you can start to evolve.
We always start with lagging indicators,
because that is mandatory.
But then we can try to shift left
to these leading indicators as well,
in order to get, you know, more time
to prevent any issues
before they actually hit your customer.
So yeah.
So Amazon CloudWatch gives you
some building blocks to detect
both kinds of indicators.
So let us see what they are.
So we'll start with detecting, you know,
leading indicators,
using anomaly detection, right.
Using machine learning algorithms.
So the first feature we have,
is the logs anomaly detection.
It allows you to basically
surface any anomalies,
within your application logs.
So, once you enable it, it's always on.
And it keeps on scanning your logs
to surface any new anomalies
within this logs, right.
The second feature that
we want to talk about,
is metrics anomaly, right.
So, this is basically
when you enable this on
your CloudWatch metrics,
it constantly goes and understands
what is the past values of the metric,
and based on that it predicts
the future values
or the baseline behavior, right
And then if any metrics
goes above or beyond
that particular threshold,
it'll show you as an anomaly.
So together they always watch your data,
your logs, your metrics,
and they are always learning
based on the past data that you have.
So let us see, logs,
anomaly detection in action.
So, here is one of the screenshots
that I took from my log group.
So you can see here, you know,
once you enable log anomaly,
you see that there are three anomalies
that got de detected.
So, let's try to focus
on this particular one, right.
So you see here, that
an unexpected pattern
got detected with the severity of error.
And then it sees that the priority
is also set to medium.
And then this is the pattern
that the feature was able to detect.
And you can also see that
how these anomalies are
actually trending, right.
How frequently they're occurring.
So, you can take action upon them.
Next is metric anomaly detection.
So here you can see that we have enabled,
you know, metric anomaly
on a standard metric called,
target response time,
which you might be using
in your load balances.
And then you can see this gray band here,
which shows you the baseline performance
or expected values.
And then anything outside of it,
either above or below
can be treated as an
anomaly as well, right.
So you can see here, this particular spike
can be used as an anomaly.
So what you can do is,
you can create alarms
on these metric enabled
with anomaly detection.
So you don't have to worry
about static threshold, right.
Because sometimes the
metric can, you know,
show some seasonal trends,
so you don't know actually
what is the right threshold, right.
So using anomaly detection
it automatically understands
what's the, you know, expected values.
And then you can set an alarm.
And it also helps you to reduce
the alert settings.
So Matheus, you had a customer
that actually used this in real scenario.
- That's true.
So, I had a customer a few years back,
so what they had do, is
they managed buildings.
And then in the buildings
they install multiple cameras.
And then what happened is when someone,
you know go across those cameras,
it just triggered the motion,
and then sends a files to S3.
And then the customer's like,
how can I make that,
you know, cheap to know
if there's a party in that building.
Like if there's a lot of people
going through that camera.
So what they've done
is they created a metric per camera,
'cause it's uploading files to S3, right.
And then they use anomaly detection
to actually note, if you know,
there's a lot of people crossing
that specific camera out of normal.
So if there's a party in afternoon ,
that was not supposed to,
then those files are
getting uploaded more often,
and then when that's when
the alarm was triggered
by using the anomaly detection.
Yeah, over to you.
- So yeah, that was a good use case.
So now let's talk about features
that can help you to
identify lagging indicators.
So again, I want to
talk about two features.
First is logs, pattern and compare.
So using this you can basically group
similar log events into patterns.
And then you can also compare
whether these patterns
are occurring in the past or not, right.
So you can maybe select
two particular timelines.
Let's say from now to
let's say last Wednesday.
And then you can compare
what is the delta of you know,
seeing this kind of patterns,
to understand if something
has drastically changed within your logs.
Second is contributor insight.
This is one of my favorite.
It is a very simple feature,
but it is very effective.
So what it does,
it helps you to find top talkers, right.
So whenever you want to understand
like what are my instances?
Which are you know,
actually degrading the performance.
Or what are the heaviest network users,
you know, that are consuming
the entire network bandwidth for example.
Or what are my API endpoints,
that are actually facing
the highest number of errors.
You can use contributor insights
to derive those
information from your logs.
So, let us try to see them in action.
So here is an example
of pattern and compare.
So as you can see on the top,
I have around 27 patterns,
but let's try to focus on some of them.
So, here is the highlighted area
which we can focus.
So one of the patterns
that we have derived,
is showing us that there's an error
called, database connection timeout.
And now what I'm also doing is,
I'm comparing it with, you know,
the current time to let's say
the last one day or last one week.
So I can see that the delta is plus 252.
That means that these are new events
that got generated after, let's say,
I made a new deployment, right
So this can tell you exactly
what is the difference of this error.
Like how many times it has occurred,
comparing it with the
past period basically.
So it can help you to quickly understand,
like whether you know,
the change that you've made
is actually working or not.
And here's an example
of contributor insights in action.
So what I'm doing here is, I've created
a contributor insight
rules on my log group,
and I'm tracking the, you know,
the payment failures for my customers
using their customer ID.
So you can see that here,
there is total of 12 unique contributors,
or 12 unique customers,
that are facing the failures.
And I'm just showing the top 10 here.
And here you can see,
that this particular customer with his ID,
he is having the highest number
of payment failures.
And then on the top,
you also get the logs getting converted
into your time series automatically,
by creating the rules.
So you can act exactly see,
what is the error trend
for this particular contributor.
So now we have, you know,
our detection mechanism in place,
that tells you that there is a problem.
But then how do we go
about investigating them,
and understanding what actually caused it?
So as a support engine and myself,
I have been on a lot of incident calls
with our customers, and
there is a common pattern
that I see, right.
You start with seeing a lot of alerts
that are going off.
Most of them are noise, right.
Which doesn't tell you exactly
what is going wrong.
And then, you know, the teams
start to dig in between,
let's say go and check
one tool for metrics,
maybe another for traces.
You know, and then check the logs.
They're trying to you know,
to piece together what
is happening, right.
They have all the data,
but that is scattered
across all these different tools.
Which takes them a lot of time
to come to the, you
know, final understanding
of what is actually happening,
and why the problem is occurring.
But imagine that at 3:00 AM
you are an on-call, right.
And then there is someone
who is actually going
and investigating all
this information for you,
and then when you actually go and check,
it tells you exactly what happened.
Wouldn't that be great?
Yeah.
So let me introduce you
to Amazon CloudWatch investigation,
which is your AI companion,
that is built right into
your CloudWatch console.
So this actually helps you,
to automatically scan and correlate
all your telemetry data that you have.
It can be your metrics, logs, traces.
Your cloud trial even changes for example.
And then it generates AI powered findings,
and root cause analysis showing exactly
what happened and why, right.
So what normally would take you hours
for investigating an issue,
it'll be able to be
completed in just minutes.
So you actually, you know, going to focus
on how to fix the problem
rather than finding it, right.
So let me walk you through
how this actually works behind the scenes.
So let's say, you know,
we start the investigation using features.
And here's your AI buddy right there.
So what what happens is that
once the investigation starts,
the agent will start
to first form the service topology.
So what do I mean by that,
is that whatever services are related
to this particular issue or investigation,
it'll try to build a map,
and see how they're interconnected.
Next, it'll then go and try to correlate
all the telemetry data
for all the services.
It can be your
applications, your services,
or your readable services.
So you see that all the input
gets scanned by the AI agent.
Like your metric logs, traces
and all the clouded events.
And then for all these telemetry data,
it tries to detect the anomalies.
Like is there a spy?
Or is there a particular
trend that it is seeing?
And it also does the pattern analysis
automatically for you.
So let's say there are some error logs
that are being generated
during the investigation,
it'll try to understand the pattern
and show it to you.
Once the entire process is completed,
you'll start to get the observations
or key findings,
and then based on that
the AI agent will create the hypothesis,
which is actually the root cause analysis
of what happened and why.
And then finally it also
gives you suggestions,
about how to fix that issue.
And then once the
investigation is completed,
generally we go and write down
the detailed incident report.
Which is, you know, time consuming,
and I mean it'll take a lot of time
to generate that kind of report.
So ,it also gives you an option
to generate an incident report
in standard format, right.
So yeah, let's try
to see that in action with a demo.
So here is my demo scenario.
It's a very, you can say
simplified e-commerce application,
that I'm running on a,
you know, EKS cluster.
So users are actually, you know,
trying to post the orders
through this particular API endpoint,
and then they're not able to, you know,
place the order
and are facing some errors, right.
So now as an on-call,
you started to get paged
and you are going to investigate this
using cloud investigation.
So let us see how that works.
So here's a demo for that.
So I am currently at the SLO page,
and you can see that
the SLO that I created
to track the order processing,
is currently unhealthy.
And I'm almost going to exhaust my budget.
So what I can do, I can click on actions,
and click on investigate.
So this will open an investigation pane,
in the same window where you can provide
a unique name to your investigation.
It's kind of like you create a ticket,
and ask the agent to work on it, right.
And then when you scroll down
you can just click on the
start investigation button,
that will trigger the AI agent
to you know, start the investigation.
So now, let's try to deep dive
into what the agent is actually doing.
So, you can open the investigation
that you just created.
So I can just open that investigation.
Yeah.
So, if you recall the workflow
that I showed you, right,
the agent will first go and you know,
create a service topology,
and try to identify what are all resources
it needs to check.
So on the top, you can
see that it is analyzing,
let's say my Java order API service,
or my Java delivery API service,
which we saw in the architecture as well,
which are part of the demo.
So what I can do, I can
click on the agent queue,
and you can exactly understand
how the agent is going to investigate,
and thinking about how to proceed, right.
So all the resources
that is going to check,
you can see that.
And now if you scroll down,
you start to get the key findings right.
So the agent has started
to now investigate the telemetry data.
It is trying to correlate it.
And here for example,
you can see that it has found
that the DynamoDB table
is actually getting throttle, right.
So we saw that again, in our architecture
that the orders are getting stored there.
And now you can see that
it is also trying to understand
any anomalies, by using the pattern
and the anomaly queries,
to check if there are any anomalies
within your logs.
And it has found some of
the anomalies as well.
And here is a metric,
that it used to confirm
that there is some
throttling happening, right.
So it's automatically checking
all the kind of data that you have,
you know, with this services.
And then giving you the key findings.
So while this is happening,
what you can also do is that,
you can go and add your own custom note.
So let's say you are a team,
and you are investigating together.
So let's say if I find
something important,
I can share that context with my team,
by just adding a custom note,
which will be part of your investigation.
So I can click on add,
and it'll add the investigation, right.
So anyone in your team can look into it,
if there is some important
information, right.
So once this is completed,
the AI agent will now
generate a hypothesis,
once it has enough evidence
of what caused the issue.
So let us now take a
look at the hypothesis,
that the agent generated for us.
Yeah.
So what I can do is, I can start,
I mean I can click on this hypothesis,
and it'll open a detailed
hypothesis information.
So you can get all the information like,
okay, what was the root cause summary.
Like what happened?
You can see that the problem
actually was the DynamoDB
table throttling.
And then exactly like the timeline
of how the investigation went.
And this is the service topology
that I was talking about.
That the agent creates a map view as well.
And then finally you see
the suggested actions.
That how you can basically
fix this particular issue.
In this case
as our DynamoDB table was throttling.
We can obviously go and increase
the right capacity on the table
and it'll basically mitigate the issue.
And you can also see some
of the troubleshooting documents,
which it can suggest to you,
which can help you to further investigate.
So what I can do is,
I can maybe open the runbook,
that it suggested,
and I can fill in the input parameters.
And then I can, you know,
try to increase the capacity
right from the same console.
So this was the demo that shows you
exactly how the investigation was.
You can see how drastically
it reduces your time to investigate
and get to a root cause much faster.
So Matheus, as a solution architect
you might be interacting
with your customers, right.
Like how they can generate
the incident report.
Is this something that they are always...
- [Matheus] Yeah, it's really important
for my customers to be able to generate
a report that they can
send to the management.
So they can understand
in details, you know,
what happened to that application.
So what can we have?
- [Jay] Yeah, we also
have that option now.
So once the investigation is completed
by the AI agent, you can just click
on the incident report button,
as you can see on the top.
So once I click,
click there,
it'll open the incident report console.
So now what the agent is doing,
is actually collecting all the facts
about the investigation.
Like what are all the details
that can be used for the
investigation purpose.
And then you can also review those facts
that the agent collected.
So for example, here, what I can do,
I can update this fact that how many
total customers I have,
how many of them got impacted?
So you can tell your executive,
that okay, this percentage of customers
were impacted by this incident.
And then once you fill all these facts,
I mean you don't have to fill everything,
but a few of them you can always edit.
And then it'll take a few minutes
to generate the incident report.
So yeah, you can see here,
the report is generated
for our investigation,
which says DynamoDB, right capacity issue.
And then it will fill it up
with all the information
that you generally would, you know,
add to your incident report.
Like what was the customer impact.
You know, what went well
during the investigation.
You know, what are the next steps
that you can use to
mitigate the problem, right?
Or what are the lesson learned
about this investigation, right?
All this information,
it'll automatically fill it up
in this particular report,
which you can then export and share it
with your, you know,
executives or stakeholders, right?
So yeah.
Yeah, this is the report
which we just created, right.
So, I'll hand it over to you now, Mathias.
- Thank you Jay.
Let's now talk about how
we resolve a problem.
So, what I wanna do now,
is jump straight into a demo.
Which uses Kiro CLI.
So you heard about Kero ID, right?
Which is an agent ID.
But now I want to talk about the Kiro CLI,
which you can run in your terminal.
So before we jump into the demo
and show you the application,
I want to explain how
the application works.
So basically you have a microphone,
and this microphone will
send a voice to a page,
and that voice will be
processed by a backend,
which is an ECS.
And then we also have
a DynamoDB in a model.
So once the voice comes in,
it will translate the voice,
we get into a text and translate
to the desired language
which will be broadcasted
to multiple users.
Right, so you have two applications here.
And then if you see,
this is how the application works.
So I'm gonna create a session.
So the first webpage,
so it's a test for reinvent.
I'm gonna add a description
for that session,
and then I'm gonna select a language.
In that case will be Portuguese.
'Cause I'm a Brazilian,
so I speak Portuguese.
And you see the next slide.
So creating the session,
you can see you can start recording.
I'll jump into the other page,
where I can join a session, right.
So, I'm then selecting
English as the output
in the text format.
And then I'll open the page.
So if you see now,
once the hour just starts streaming,
you're gonna see
from the original language to English,
as we select a language.
And then here, in that page
is where you can see the
two boxes in in yellow.
That's where the outer will go in,
and then broadcast the text out.
So let's see that working.
(Matheus speaking in Portuguese)
So, as you can see I was
speaking in Portuguese,
and I got that translated near real time
to the other side in English, right.
So, I heard from a...
To simulate here, just heard from a user
complaining that the user
cannot create a session, right.
So you just saw that we
recreated in the sample,
but the user just said no,
I cannot create a session.
And then what we're gonna do,
do an investigation using Kiro CLI.
So what I have here, my terminal,
inside of the folder called, platform,
and then that folder contains the CDK.
I've used the CDK to deploy
the whole infrastructure.
And I'm gonna run Kiro CLI.
So, once I run Kiro
CLI, it starts loading.
And then as you can see
I'm running multiple MCP.
So extends the LLM by you know,
loading ECS MCP, the CloudWatch,
the documentation.
Playwrights, which is an important MCP
in that troubleshooting, can you see?
And also application
signals, as Jay mentioned.
So that's also using Claud Sonnet 4.5.
And then I'll paste the prompts now.
So ,I'll clear the session,
and then I'll paste a prompt for the LLM.
So as you can see,
I'm asking the LLM to
go and open the page,
and try to create a session.
I'm not providing details where to click,
how to click in the HML,
just saying go and simulate a session.
I'm also providing details below,
saying, do not change anything in AWS
without my permission, right.
Also below I'm telling
about the infrastructure.
So I'm saying there's a CDK
in that folder where you were loaded.
Also I'm telling there's an AWS profile
called RIV,
which gives access to
the AWS infrastructure.
Like Route 53, CloudFormation.
And I'm also telling the LLM,
that where the backend source code is.
So, if you press enter,
the LLM or the Kiro CLI,
we now start thinking
and trying to simulate
that create session, right.
So despite being recorded,
at this stage, I'm not touching anything.
So the LLM of the Kiro CLI
is actually going through
and trying to figure out
how to create the session,
and trying to simulate the user.
So as you can see on your screen,
it's saying can you see the page,
and then checking for the console logs.
Its also waiting for the
browser to finally load,
and say, Oh actually I found
how to create a session,
and now start populating the session
with the details.
Like just fake details.
You know, test session.
I was gonna select a language,
and trying to create a session.
And at this stage you can see
that this session cannot be created.
Right so when you saw the first time
it could create a session,
it could translate,
but at this stage it's failing.
So if I continue processing,
now what Kiro CLI is doing,
is gonna dive deep into
the AWS infrastructure.
So be querying the AWS,
CLI to you know, to understand
about the route53.
Where is that domain pointing?
What are the records
used in that hosted zone?
See's listing the resource there.
And you can see I found
that the DNS records.
And then now it's gonna go into
the load balancer.
Is there any health target there?
Is he pointing to anything
behind the scenes?
So let's continue, it's
going to the listeners.
We'll check for...
See if there's any 443 connections.
Going to the load balances.
So it's scribing the rules.
So just continue.
Yeah, checking if there's
any health targets
in the backend.
And now it's touching the ECS.
As you remember I had
the ECS as my backend.
And then what it's saying is,
I found an issue with your ECS.
So let's continue to debug.
And then as you can see
there is a red message there.
And Jay, as you work in the support team,
what does the Error mean?
- [Jay] So basically what happened,
like the LM tried to use
a made up cluster name in the beginning,
but this was not existing, right?
We had something else
using the name with the cluster.
So, in the first place it failed.
But then it automatically understood
that I need to go and
grab the cluster names.
So what it does, in the next call,
you can see it makes use
of the list cluster repair call,
and then automatically tries to list
the actual cluster name.
So, it is doing it on its own,
and trying to list the
right set of cluster
that we have basically.
- [Matheus] Thank you Jay.
So we'll continue.
So now it's listing the the service,
so we have a service,
and then in the ECS service
we have the tasks, right.
So it's describing the service now.
It actually, it found the root cause.
And then as you can, it's highlighting
that the desire counts in the ECS
for that specific service, is zero.
Which means we don't have a backend,
so there's no container
running behind the scenes.
And then what Kiro CLI is gonna do now,
is gonna provide me a root cause,
and how to go and fix the problem.
So as you can see,
it gives me detailed information
of what was the problem.
So if you think about
what the problem was,
that's the screenshots of the ECS,
and then the container is stopped,
so there's no backend.
That's what Kiro CLI found
through the curing the AWS backend.
So now what I'm saying to Kiri CLI,
go and then add another container, right?
So change the desired account to 021,
and then test it again.
So, Kiro CLI is running a command,
adding an extra container to that service.
And then if you see it's
waiting for 60 seconds.
I just sped up the video
just to avoid us waiting.
But it's just waiting
for the container to warm up.
And then checking if now
the container is healthy,
and then starting again the same test
you've done before, to see if you know,
now you can create a session.
Let's see if, if you can create a session,
if it actually solved the problem.
So we'll provide the details
of the session name,
similar to what I've done before.
Select a language and
then create a session.
Here we go.
So now it's able to create a session.
Right, so Kiro CLI was able to go,
and then simulate a user.
You know, do all the testing.
Go into AWS, understand
the whole environment.
'Cause I haven't provided,
like this is my ECS.
This is where the task is.
So it was able to figure
out all the details,
find the root cause.
And once I provide a command
it just went there, and
then fixed the problem.
So, if you see, now we
have a running container
in the backend.
Alright, and then we are about to finish.
I just wanted you to think for a second,
what matters more in our use case?
Is it the light?
So if you see for my use case,
the server is down,
but my wife could, you know,
continue to use the lights.
Is it better?
Or maybe the server was working
without any problem,
but the lights were
not, you know, working.
And here's where I wanted you
to start to think about working backwards
from your customer.
And understanding how critical
is the application, and defining
with the business you know,
how to deal in case you
have those situations.
And then, let's get the key takeaways
for the day.
So, in the case we talked
about backup, right.
So in my case I could
have provided a candle,
so my wife would be able to do her,
you know, organize her
breakfast, using a candle.
I also could have, you know,
organized a game day.
And in the family we understand
how to proceed in case we had a bad day.
Or as Jay mentioned, we
could have dashboards
to understand how the
environment's operating.
Create alarms, so if there's an issue,
I get alerted.
Also, it's really, really important
to define the SLAs, SLOs, SLIs.
Get the business together.
Right, I've seen a lot of customers
where it defined all of those numbers
but they don't have, you know,
the connection with their customers
with the business.
And lastly, as we all talked about AIs,
I could have for example Alexa,
and say, Alexa, go and
fix the lights for me.
So, I hope you all have
enjoyed the session.
One thing that I would ask you to do is,
in your app you should
have access to the survey.
It's really, really important for us,
'cause I do actually read
all of the, you know, feedback.
'Cause that way we
improve our next session.
And then here's the Call to action,
so you can scan and learn more
about what we discussed.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)